des frappes aériennes pour lutter contre
des groupes armés soutenus par la
turquie moscou confirme avoir mené des
raids dans la province d'idlib
conformément à ce qu'avait annoncé le
centre russe pour la réconciliation des
parties en syrie
le 20 février 2020 des bandes armées
terroristes ont perpétré plusieurs
attaques massives au moyen de nombreux
véhicules blindés contre des unités
gouvernementales en direction de mine
hassaï rab à la demande du commandement
syrien
les avions sukhoï su 24 des forces
aérospatiale de russie ont effectué des
frappes sur les bandes armés terroristes
qui avaient réalisé une percée afin de
les empêcher de s'avancer à l'intérieur
du territoire syrien la porte parole de
la diplomatie russe a réaffirmé la
coopération militaire mise en place avec
l'armée syrienne tout d'abord vous ne
devez pas oublier que nous parlons d'un
état souverain
les forces armées syriennes sont sur
leur territoire ce devrait être un
principe de base
bien sûr il y à la coopération existante
de la syrie avec les militaires russes
et venant d'autres pays
je pense que la communauté
internationale ne doit pas oublier le
principe de base selon ankara ses
frappes auraient tués deux soldats turcs
y en aurait blessé cinq autres
par ailleurs le ministère turc de la
défense déclare avoir éliminé 50 cibles
syriennes dans la région d'idlib
face à ces nouvelles violences l'union
européenne appelle à l'arrêt de
l'offensive militaire des forces de
damas dans la zone la nouvelle offensive
militaire du régime syrien et de ses
alliés à idlib qui provoque d'énormes
souffrances humaines est il acceptable
l'union européenne appelle tous les
acteurs à cesser immédiatement les
hostilités et demande instamment à
toutes les parties au conflit de
permettre un accès humanitaire directe
et sans entraves à tous ceux qui sont
dans le besoin pour mettre un terme aux
affrontements adlib au sommet entre la
russie la france l'allemagne et la
turquie pourraient avoir lieu selon
moscou
[Musique]